- September 22, three years ago.
My future is in LA at BuzzFeed.
I honestly feel my future there.
That's where I fit
professionally, like my skills
and interest and personality.
I am dedicating my time
and thought to being there.
(melancholy music)
- I started here at
BuzzFeed very interestingly.
- Before I was working
here, I was a morning
show reporter.
- I actually went to
culinary school and while
I was in college I made,
like, dumb little, You Tube
videos and as I started
to kind of play with that,
I really started to enjoy
the process of editing
and filming.
- So I started as a small You Tuber.
I used to make cause play
videos, animated videos,
and actually two years
ago, I applied to BuzzFeed
but I didn't get it.
- I moved to Montana to do
the news which was sort of
what I thought I wanted to do but I was
really unhappy there.
I hated doing the news; I hated the cold;
I was always alone.
- I had just lost my job; I
got fired to be more precise.
- I was at Sephora working
and what I really loved to do
was helping people find
confidence in themselves
no matter what.
So I was doing my little makeup at Sephora
and then I started seeing a few videos on
body-positive stuff coming
from this BuzzFeed thing
and I was like "What the (bleep) is that"?
- And I remember when I was
still in Montana wishing
I could move back to LA but
wasn't sure what I wanted
to do so I eventually
realized I want to make videos
that make people forget
what their going through.
- A friend of mine that was
working here gave me the
suggestion to start writing
just on BuzzFeed.com.
He was like "You want to work at BuzzFeed?
They hire people from the
post that, you know, anybody
posts."
- There was a point in my
life where it was really
hard to find a job.
I would apply to all these
places and for some reason
I would never get hired
and I wondered if there was
something wrong with me, like,
if I'm not doing it right.
- When I looked into it and
I applied for a position
that I wasn't even qualified for.
- I was sitting up watching
a lot of late night tv and
I watched this episode
of the Jimmy Fallon Show
with Christina Aguilera.
I was watching and she
did this impersonation of
Brittany Spears.
- This little piggy went to the market.
- So I was quickly, like,
"Oh (bleep), let me write
this article real quick"
and next thing I know, like,
it was on the homepage
the next day and it got a
million views.
- Two weeks later I got an audition.
And, my audition, sure
enough, was here for BuzzFeed.
And I didn't get it but
the person signing me in
at the desk asked me
my name and he was like
"Wow there's something
about you; you have a look,
you have the sounds".
So, I give him my head shot;
he tells me that I should
meet someone so right after
my audition he introduces
me to the team lead for Better Like.
- I was writing a lot of
these and a lot of my posts
were getting, like, a million
hits before I was even here.
- Two years passed and I
remember BuzzFeed again and I
just had this random thought,
like, oh BuzzFeed, that's
something I really wanted
to do; might as well try it.
- And then within two weeks,
I heard back and they were
really interested in all the
cooking competitions I had
done, my professional
experience in restaurants.
- A few weeks later they
call me in from my head shot
to film a video.
(foreign language)
And, I did an amazing job,
I guess because they called
me again and they called me
again and then they called
me again.
- I was going into an
interview actually that morning
and I get a phone call from
this number and I answer
my phone at that point and
now I don't answer any phone
calls but if its a 310 number,
I'm answering it because
I don't have a job.
- Well it turns out they took
me for an interview to be
a fellow which here that
means you have to have actual
like, technical skills and
I had zero technical skills.
So, I came in for an interview
with Eugene of all people.
I was just like yeah I love
fashion; look at me; I'm
fashionable; I love fashion.
And, then they're like "What
about your technical skills".
And, I was like technically
I love fashion and then
I just moved on.
- So Dave from HR was on the
other line and he was like
"Is this Nick Gillery and I
was like yes, this is Nick
and he was just like so
we saw your community post
and Macie who runs the
curation team would love to
have you in for an interview.
Are you available to
come in this afternoon?"
I said yes so fast before my
life, I was like absolutely
yes.
- And that was that!
- After I was graduated I
got a call like two or three
days later and they offered
me the job officially.
- They gave me a shot and
three months in after that
they offered me a BuzzFeed producer role.
- It was really funny coming
across that journal entry
because that's exactly what
I did; I moved home with the
intent of working at BuzzFeed;
I interviewed; I didn't
get it and I was devastated.
But I knew it just a matter
of time and so I applied
again and I interviewed
again and I got it.
- The day that I got the phone
call from BuzzFeed telling
me that I was hired was the
most amazing feeling that
I have ever had.
That day, I remember checking
my bank account and I only
had like six dollars in my
account and it didn't matter
because I was just so happy.
- I didn't book the job that
I initially came to audition
for; I don't remember what
it even was but I ended up
where I needed to be.
- Regardless of whatever road
blocks lie in your way, if
you feel in your heart that
you belong somewhere, you
belong doing something
then keep chasing it.
- You should keep fighting
for, keep doing the things
you love.
- Whether you want to be a
doctor, whether you want to
be a lawyer, an athlete,
anything you want to do, you
can do.
You are the God of your
own universe and you can
create the path that you
want to be on so put you mind
to it and you can do
whatever you want to do.
Trust me because it worked for me.
(melancholy music)